hey Doug Walker Here I am doing a veal
AAG on the visit a sadly Rob is still
out of town he's coming back tonight
though
and there's two movies I really really
wanted to see and that's the visit and I
also want to see Hotel Transylvania 2
but I was out of town I'm back now
and it's closer to October this makes
sense yeah I don't get why they release
into September well I kind of do but
it's that early September alright I'm
getting off track this is a visit this
is the newest Shyamalan film I really
want to see this even before it got
suppose a good reviews which really
shocked me uh so yeah the the I'll start
by saying the critical feedback of this
film has mostly been positive I mean not
like through the roof positive but I
mean like I was like 67% last I looked
or something like that is pretty good
for a shower on film that's amazing uh
and then the UH feedback I've been
getting from audiences and people and
stuff like that is kinda half and half
mostly leaning towards good uh but the
big thing people are saying oh this is
sha Milan's big comeback and this is
he's back to form and he's great and
then the other half are kind of saying
no look this is goodbye
Shyamalan standards okay this is still
awkwardly written awkwardly acted it's
still bizarre and there's a lot of stuff
that doesn't make sense and some say
it's a dark comedy some say it's a
horror film some say it's a thriller a
suspense and you know all this stuff I'm
hearing all these things so I finally
went to see this movie
all of them are right like it's in my
opinion like everything that said about
this movie is pretty much correct it's
just gonna come down to your personal
preference I mean I guess as most movies
do but I think this more than others um
the film if you don't know is about two
kids who go to see their long-lost
grandparents uh them and their mother
had a falling out so the mother allows
them to go see the grandparents because
again content with them after years and
years and yeah the grandparents are just
odd and they're strange and they do
weird things and the kids film
everything it's a found footage movie
and yeah you're just trying to figure
out if it what is going on is this
legit something they should be afraid of
or they just old people being old people
as they put it in the film uh and okay
so when the movie started out I'm
watching it I'm saying it's a shallow on
film I mean there's never a moment where
I 100% believed the actors um but again
it's better than most of his other films
I sort of put it on the first Paranormal
Activity quality acting um which I know
a lot of people say is good acting I
don't care that I think it's I think
it's not very convincing but um but
here's the thing though the writing is
still kind of awkward
they still don't quite talk right but
there's a little bit of an excuse in it
um like the girl for example is filming
everything she wants to be a filmmaker
she can be a little pretentious that's
allowed uh the boy wants to be a rapper
stay with it uh wants to be a rapper and
he's obviously a little ah he's a little
white kid from the suburbs and stuff he
wants to be a rapper ah but the raps are
funny and that like oh my god they're
really trying to make us laugh with this
they're legitimately funny and the kids
performance with it is a lot of fun the
old people are strange so you know
you're catalysing to them and it's like
okay this this kind of works you don't
know quite what's going on with them and
uh the only I could never quite fully
like I'm having trouble with this is the
mother you don't see much of her but
every time she's on screen again I just
think like you know oh we're in Nica
acting from Paranormal Activity like
just it's really awkward really weird uh
and it's never convincing but um I think
it beggars a bit at the end that's
that's okay but yeah so this stuff is
going on and I'm watching it and like I
said there's these awkward isms going on
that's emotional on films but they're
toned down and I'm still interested in
what's gonna happen I'm there's despite
the problems with it there's enough
charm and intrigue that I'm going I'm
interests I want to see this to the end
and I
wants you to the end for the right
reasons I don't want to see okay oh it's
so bad it's good it said no I
legitimately want to know what's going
on and I want to make sure these two
kids get out okay if there's even
anything to worry about the film is very
good at not giving away whether it's
very good not giving away what's going
on uh there's a few hints and actually I
I almost got it I have like server
feeling what was going on and then when
they actually do get to the reveal it's
just like you don't dammit how how did I
not put this together I felt like such a
doofus um but I like that too I like a
film that legitimately tricked me um but
the other good thing about that two good
things about that one is that they lead
you into a lot of directions thinking it
might be something else and they're done
very well they're good MacGuffins
because once you do know what's going on
they still work this is still stuff they
would hint to and they would say and so
on so forth uh but the other thing even
if you do figure out what's going on
discounting the sixth sense in this way
even if you figure out what's going on
it's still entertaining in fact you
could make the argument it's more
entertaining uh and that's a really good
that's a good way of telling a story
yeah I always say that's sort of the
testament of a really good stories even
if you know beginning and what's gonna
happen you still want to see it you're
still intrigued by how it's done and
what's going on uh so there's that but
now let me get to the best part at it no
spoilers don't worry I give it away but
the last third of this movie I don't
think I have ever been in such a state
of suspense and laughter at the same
time and again for the right reasons
it's not a it's so bad it's good thing I
was legitimately laughing my head off
throughout the whole last third of this
movie but also like really concerned
what's gonna happen and it's really
really suspenseful and it's I always
want to see a movie that was both scary
and funny at the same time and I never
got in that movie there's some movies
I've come close evil that too is kind of
close but it's like it's it's not really
scary were you ever legitimately scared
in that movie or like I think the
closest thing I ever came to was like
the librarian scene in ghostbusters
that's both really creepy and funny at
the same time you're going up and you're
going the whole climax of this movie is
like that and I'm trying to control my
laughter in throughout throughout the
last third of this movie because most
everyone else in the theater is really
creeped out and they're really oh and I
guess they were more sucked in by the
scariness of it than the comedy but
there is definitely comedy it is just it
is a beautiful mix of comedy and
suspense and horror and it's just a
blast the whole movie is worth it just
for this last third and even before that
though like I said I was interested to
know what was happening what was going
on these actors still had to deal with
really hard to say dialogue that's just
not very natural but I say about 50% of
the time
I believe it and there's enough charm to
them that I say okay I I want to know
like I said I wanna know what's gonna
happen to these people and I am
concerned for them i cancer they get
through and even some of the quirks that
Shyamalan just you know jugs in your
face in these movies uh I saw them
introduced I'm going okay
pyaare gonna do this like you know the
kids a germaphobe the girl being a
really pretentious filmmaker uh but all
of it especially the germaphobe thing
does come into play and it actually does
tie in very well and very naturally um
cuz I really thought this was gonna be
for us as it's gonna be awkward but but
it works okay um like once in a while
but make a reference to the germaphobe
thing to a point where you kind of
forget it's like oh yeah and your can't
stay a little wait Arthur series
crawling around the dirt and the snow so
when he'd be like concerned about that
but I don't know it could be a flub with
the movie whatever um there's a lot of
little things like that a lot of details
like first of all this camera is way too
fucking
for any suburban kid to have I mean even
the size of them I know these cameras I
can get like really detailed uh you know
a really good picture
you know from small sizes but I mean
like this is these are clearly really
high-end cameras um and the microphones
on them must be the fucking best in the
world you know you can hear the
grandparents from miles away talking so
it's one of those things where it's like
the little details if you don't like
this movie it's 100 percent
understandable and I'm not going to be
like how can you possibly it don't it's
still awkward there's still a ton of
problems with it but the stuff that's
good for me was good enough to say you
know what I'm really glad I saw this
movie and it was very enjoyable honestly
from beginning to end I can't think of
any times where I was like we're doing
this okay let's go and stuff but it's
really from beginning to end it was a
lot of fun and it was short it was just
the right length it was just the right
amount um well okay in my opinion
offended maybe three minutes earlier
there's an additional three minutes
where it's like okay I see why you have
that but man if you went to three
minutes earlier one that just been like
going out on a high note but you had to
give kind of like the sentimental ending
and stuff it's like okay whatever any
it's not badly written you know that to
his credit but I'm like oh if you went
to three minutes later I will just say
like you know what's the last third is
so much fun
um so yeah that's uh that's kind of my
take on it uh if you if you cannot get
past those awkward moments of writing
and and some awkward acting and stuff
like that a lot of it comes from the
writing honestly the the acting I say
maybe with the exception of the mother
it mostly it's these people trying to
make this dialogue sound natural and
it's just it's still Shyamalan dialogue
it's very tricky to to you know but but
it's still that 50% when they get it
right for me was good enough um and the
story and the pacing everything what was
so enjoyable to me
but there are still plot holes there are
still things that don't make sense and
if that kind of stuff really gets to you
like I get it there's people are not
gonna be able to overlook that and fair
enough
you know it's you're supposed to be
suspending your disbelief for this and
they suspend it too much but for me
there was just enough to make it
legitimately enjoyable and a lot of fun
um even at the points where I'm kind of
rolling my eyes and moaning at some of
the dialogue um like I said I really
legitimately wanted to know where this
was going and and it was throwing me for
a lot of loops I didn't know it will way
are they going this direction are they I
think it kind of noise shell Milan's
writing it's like are they gonna go this
route because he's gone this stupid
route before like he's gone this really
really bad route and I don't know
it could still go that way I mean we
don't know how far Shama has come or
whatever uh but it goes just the right
direction and it misleads you in just
the right ways and it gives enough hints
in just the right way is that even if
you figure it out it's still a lot of
fun to watch a it's a lot of fun to see
uh what's going on it's fun to see the
interaction even if you know what's
going on so um yeah that's about it I
hope somehow that helps clear that out
uh like I said I totally understand when
somebody says this is still stupid it's
better than most of his stuff but it's
still stupid don't go see it and I
understand when people say man this was
a lot of fun I I highly recommend in
everything so it's it's just gonna
depend on what you can overlook and what
you're kind of focusing on like I said I
for me there was enough charm and
intrigue and good storytelling to say
okay I'm I'm on board for this I'm you
know sorta I'm being dragged a little
bit but I put a block in a little bit
too I'm like no no okay I still want to
get there Evie to get dragged me through
some of it uh and and I'm glad I bought
I'm glad to get dragged along I'm glad I
went from walking the you know the line
to go on to sort of jogging to like
running like I really wanna know what's
going I really wanna know what's
happening so and I can't think of the
last time I've said that about a shout
one movie um and on you know or but on
top of the Shyamalan movie thing like I
said it's the first film were in the
last third uh I was legitimately uh
scared and laughing at the same time and
I always want a movie that did that and
I finally got it who would have thought
Shyamalan would be the one to do it and
to do it in the right way uh but I
finally got it for me is there another
one out there possibly but I haven't
seen it yet and it was so much fun and I
was just it like I said the last third
is just a blast and the lead-up to it in
this it is a lot of fun too so um yeah
that's about it people hopefully I shall
be with you tomorrow or soon I should
say I'm gonna try and see you tomorrow
for Hotel Transylvania 2 you know I
really like the first one so I'm curious
to see what now the second one is and
yeah that's about it I shall see you
later